so I think as saying if the people said
here I shall really suck my students
while carrying this work and this reason
we're talking about three or four papers
all five student have really made the
major contributions and Jamie's here the
res are not so a simple hard question on
the second part first lease for the
first project I'm not here so here what
we try to do science and interpretation
right the you GDP our 2016 keeps right -
explanation so near why I am and these
are the projects really only the
interpretation so I was at an iPad
workshop in May oh good point
so there was a startup co-founder who
was using deep learning for radiology
and she said that FD a wants her to
interpret her algorithms so it's really
coming to a lot of regulation especially
come to precision medicine where the
stack is much higher than they losing
some money and losing a few customers
right it was live on stake so this
mission-critical applications of deep
learning I really needs us to be very
careful an interval bility
interpretation can really help us to be
more trustworthy my own group have been
working on genomics and we really want
to help scientists to design experiments
to find genes in the right interaction
form so that they can do experiments and
also let me try to work with
neuroscientists try to do neuroscience
and this project I'll talk about later
can we characterize neurons in a way
that physiologists have been doing and
use deep learning and the last one Jamie
was very much engaged always the drivers
that we want to interpret to a generic
kind of deep learning interpretation
with some hierarchical structures and as
I said you say we my group do we do
machine learning for science and there's
a new name I like quite a lot of
scientific machine learning so let me
try to define scientific machine
learning uses machine learning for
scientific research to track information
for discovery knowledge I also try to be
scientific principle in machine learning
Eragon how's that fly towering couple
months ago people try to build in
physics principles intuitive learners so
it's both ways and you want to iterate
and the result are subject to scientific
standards for me particularly is gia
gallant my colleague in your side his
standard I would have to say that it's
very high specially on writing but I
complain about paper we have worked with
him for five years as a derating he said
we have written papers over six years so
the time scale is much longer and if you
assume that IQs in the two fields are
equal the papers are much better written
and it's much easier for us to build on
each other's work so that's what I like
and we have different people in my group
try to do interpret bility genomics
natural language processing and also
deep like a neuroscience while we really
got upset together to do this paper try
to defy really what do mean by
interpromotional Lonnie and Jamie &
Chandon
the first two also really drove the
project and with some help from the rest
of us so we defined interpromotional
learning we decide we cannot deal with
general inter people are there you have
to go to a philosopher you go to
psychology you go to the English sticks
it's not something we feel like we can
handle or anybody so we define
interpromotional learning as the
extraction of relevant information from
a machine or any model concerning
relationship either containing data or
learn by the model and we emphasize that
we have to have an audience to really
identify into the bility and a chosen
problem and there's actions to follow
with communication and discovery
so in well is your graph we have a
problem
say we wanted radiology for some medical
images and we have a group of people say
doctors who we really want to this
interpretation for patients that's a
different interview leti a bar and we
want to use predictability as accuracy
as a way to see the model has to capture
things in the data the wanting interpret
things has nothing to do with data and
also you have to have descriptive
accuracy and you can try to do this keep
your accuracy place on or interpolate
the under model or after the model is
faded and you need relevancy for both
the previous model based in turbidity
and
the ad-hoc an analysis to the problem
you're trying to solve so this is just a
more extended version in the interest
time I just find out that a prediction
accuracy you have global for the whole
average you should also look at the
prediction based on each data point and
the UJ there's a trade-off not always
right we like to think that this is
increased but if you think about
actually this is increase with
relatively shallow our interpreter why
you have this in which the type of
thousand I don't think that's really
interval anymore hello jet regression or
linear models again you can you do with
a million terms you know a few questions
it's relative small things we think
they're pretty descriptive and random
forests because has some decision trees
and that's what we like in genomic work
we haven't seen in my group deep
learning beats random foreign internment
ability and results and also deep
learning it's it's probably another
scale if you have a model when you try
to feed the model we if you can get the
same prediction I could see you like
sparsity which most of us were great and
also something we added I think it's
very interesting it's similar abilities
like how can you that human she really
simulate the process of decision so for
shallow trees I talked to a doctor
emergency doctor he said he remember
about ten decision rules when he's
working as a nurse
which is either the Casey's emergency
modularity do you have parts you can
take that relatively simplify things
also you have something like credit
score in banking that domain-based each
engineer and then you can use machine
learning statistical answer to come up
with teacher later may become part of
the knowledge and that's about the model
and also maybe you cannot do any of that
like deep learning you have to really
rely on other masters people cook up
with like importance measures for
interactions pestis scores and
visualization and also you can look at
local interruptions and alternative
that's what I'll be talking about which
other so both for the rest of the talk
we'll be talking about two particular
projects and the first is kind of doing
global predictably and later to look at
individual ones actually suppose for the
first product you both are post hoc
interpret promotions I relate to deep
learning here here fits the theme of the
workshop and the segment's a general
method called agglomerative contactor
decomposition which is beaut contact UT
conversation Jamie did when he was
started Adam Google printer so the first
project has been going on at least three
years possibly four if I count right so
it's a project where being really caught
the good predictive results very early
on like three years ago I've been
struggling with the inter popularity
question for science and led by reason
you answer the two first author for my
group I switched Jacqueline's lab on
campus whom I have been working for the
last 15 years and I am using Google now
in powder Mike he said Allen Institute
and bang Wilma is Oxford resides
returned to UCSF says that Cody and UNC
joining Duke
so the approach we take in my group for
scientific machine learning actually we
embed our students on site
so they go to group meetings which we
try to become a scientist if anything
that's what we like to do and we take a
scientific problem and we generalize
when we saw this particular problem so
my approach I mean I came a pretty
radical background 30 years ago so some
the older people I knew from my last run
the theory work in the 90s and then
which analyzers so that the philosophy
here is a solve a problem and it saw one
problem and then I think you have more
power to generalize to other problems
I'm definitely over my career I pay a
lot more attention to empirical is not
just simulation and simulation can be
used by design by small in the trenches
to see something really work and then I
really want to do theory now that's why
one we're coming back to more theory and
so comment down those out to both the
talks I heard earlier I think it's a
very good start but the next thing I
think would be the next important step
is actually find a real problem that
have a perturbation resolve and maybe
you'll give the input to revise the
model and to get to do the next round of
theory I think there'll be a healthy
cycle so here we have this very
difficult elusive area of visual cortex
priming with your card called v4 so we
went like a bar edge detectors and we
have this feed forward Network the real
biological network and well we have deep
learning network right and if you ask
apologists at least a couple years ago
they didn't think deep learning really
capture anything because it's not
biological and this we won with
b2 before it's one of the major video
pathways is try to send information
about what we are looking at there's
also a where pathway and before has been
very very hard for years to figure out
what it does
so the the scientific kind of input we
get from the food is really say how to
scientists capture or characterize a
neuron and this is a video called
internet like the Nobel prize-winning
work by
have a wizard in the late 50s to figure
out we won it's kind of first layer of
deep learning you reproduce that with
large data it's just orientation
selectivity for orientation location and
so what you're hearing is the flowering
of a particularly burner on what the cat
is looking at is on the screen you can
see that one find the right location in
terms of causality induce a causal
reaction so this is basically prove that
we've an URL terrible location we Forge
very different story so I don't know I
didn't do the history on how a harbor
will figure it out
with that data we could have all gotten
nobel prize right so how did it get
there to figure out
they said the stimuli to let the sleepy
cat to look at so v4 has been very
elusive because people at least for the
last 20 years I've been doing where
geometric composition of stimuli and see
whether we found your own gets excited
so at an anatomically they figure out
this is a v4 region but they don't know
what it does so they come up with these
different shapes very geometric so if
you like it you get it if you're not you
you have to design that something else
so that's why we hope to help and people
also do this or this curvature right you
can see it's very detailed about and
then try it and to see whether we found
your engage excite it's very very
inefficient to figure out how many round
works so Jack's life is always into a
natural language and that not nitro
stimuli I mean 20 15 years ago I was
working start working with him it was
kind of not quite accepting now I think
the feel really accepted we should use
natural stimuli to stimulate the brain
is it
there's very geometric shapes so the
data was collected by bang Wilma who is
not in Oxford we took him two years so
this is all very expensive data work
with a primate to get the data as you
get the primate macaca to fixate at the
center of the screen and then with all
kinds of rewards and you shown things
random selected from this old database a
black and white and see the wonder we
found you're also excited
and you try to do more so let me on this
track since 2013 with Julian Mara Europe
and Romanian we did our first work got
the state out prediction performance
what we mean by state-of-the-art we
compared with v2 which is a easier video
cortex simply meet the prediction
performance we declare a success that's
what mean by state-of-the-art so we used
basically two layer direction dictionary
learning with some sift features and
also with the orientation and we got the
best result and parallels and the color
scoop at MIT have been very similar
party Mulcair by IT but not doing also
before so the help a little different
not exactly natural images they have
Sammy in the beginning and now they also
used their treatment so I'd be on this
parallel path they have published a
predict worker and we have been wanting
to do interpretation so I'll come back
to how our work compare right now so for
us actually we can kind of replicating
the Carlos work and from scientific
scientists in training actually were
quite happy to be on par with the top
lab yes
it's that single show it's the average
firing rate of a single neuron thank you
for the question so each neuron you
observe which is randoms like images a
firing rate and for the test data will
help 10 replicates so it's a better fire
rate estimation than okay so two
questions we said like five years ago
want to do is how do we care to rise
before neurons remember we in the same
tradition of physiology and want to find
stimuli that excite make the new rung
fire that's basic we define what we mean
by care to write new row and if we could
do that we can find these images from
data hopefully more natural then it's
geometric shapes we can also feedback to
the closed loop experiments and increase
the efficiency of neuroscience
experiments also as somebody in the
middle machine learning and science we
also want to help answer this question
that to convolution that neural network
really resemble bringing at all in the
meadow try to interface the two and so
that's why we first my remember to layer
dictionary learning and I think three
years ago I was giving a talk and Joshua
Benjy was speaking after me he was doing
deep learning already and looked like I
made up my own our own deep learning
network base we saw a small data so we
decide to try to learning that's why I
got into deep learn I actually worked
pretty well so let me tell you exactly
what do we do
so we basically transfer learning we
just took people trained Alex net and do
some simple regression to connect with
the neuro firing rate and then we end up
quickly with 18 models with very similar
prediction that's why we struggle with
interpretation about 3 years I'll show
you what we end up with and I have to
say that I was very surprised how the
imagenet deep learning as a future
extraction worked really well
for my cake data so that's what we have
heard a lot about imagenet and other
people trained it right we didn't fall
classifications of a thousand classes so
what we did we have black and white
which is took the first two layers a
speech extraction no change nothing
about them a cake and we just made three
channels fly
why into color we didn't alter anything
- Taylor - and then we did a regression
reach and the soup and we did slightly
better than a handmade deep Learning
Network
so basic is saying that one conjectures
that this early layer of deep learning a
kind of universally capture some
structure about primate context this is
she
wise transfer learning you have color
image to black and white our image had
nothing to do with image net and you
have very high level tasks - very micro
level neuron responses but we do need
some lassoo to match so in that sense
you transfer color or black and white
from human to my cake and from
high-level tasks to low level neuron
responses and actually not just layer
two we did layer too many layers work
and then the question is suppose we take
my now come back to the many layer and
many network so suppose you want to look
at a particular model field we do this
is from a model I connect plus lesser or
reach how do you describe your model
like post hoc analysis
did you remember has started with
physiology they want to find images to
excite a neuron so here I have a model
new wrong it's a deep learning plus
regression if we maximize this motor
neuron somehow I'm trying to say these
are the predicted patterns this new run
will care about we didn't do exactly the
model because 2 rogg we did some
regularization about smoothing the
images to kind of constrain the search
space a bit smooth than just any
possible and that's what we go so one
contract is that actually this neuron
like curvature right remember we know we
found your like curvature we saw these
various geometric shapes of different
curvature and we also did compression
and so I come back to the complexity
question that's why counting the number
of weights it's not a good idea can
easily compress it by 50% to take so
this is a perturbation by removing
futures and reduced by 50%
and you still see this courage
so we try to find different ways to
convince that this is a curvature knew
wrong now you look at all the image we
have a much smaller database right so we
look at the database and pick these
images that excite the model around it's
the model now you see curvature again
but you don't see this dry these
periodic stripes and that's model based
so we look at the raw test data this has
no model we look at the peak you also
see some courage so all of these try to
confirm that the curvature we saw from
the tip team which is really a
derivative of a deep dream that seemed
to capture something and then there are
a lot of other model vgg and Google net
and they give very similar prediction
performance like correlation 0.92 you
have less you you have rich okay
you have very similar performance so
quickly and not just layer two you have
large three therefore well now it's 18
models you're very similar performance
so this is the model hacking right those
most really you do cherry-picking but we
like to be transparent and report all of
that so the question how can we come up
with the interpretation that reflect all
18 models from the evidence they all do
well in terms of relation so that's
where the stability comes in so I mean
the right day definitely so at least for
the last five six years I've been
advocating and my group two for
stability as a basic principle for data
science and try to integrate different
data Aggron perturbations and as a
minimum requirement for interpret bility
reproducibility and scientific
hypothesis generation so you can call it
robust this the reason I did it because
you're busted here's I mean something
different but now I'm just putting
everything in Behrens so I said we have
18 models if you do this actually random
initialization doesn't change things
visually too much so change Deepam all
the different layers you do see
different you see curvature but they're
different
right google nod has a lot of the I like
things also seen do
alik tonight seem to have bigger
intervals between the curves and
Gurunath has smaller ones and but we all
great you see some curvature there and
so while I was giving talk I've been
giving these talks were since a bit for
the last couple of years last year I
would say the workshop that bands and
people were not happy with this 18
images it said they want one so we went
back to the drawing table and Ian series
I came up with this great idea of
introduce stability at the gradient
level right so we really doing
greediness and undefeated model for each
individual deep tuned images now if we
combine the HTML at an acronym a
Griezmann level and we're going to work
to the model with the smallest gradient
and a particular point and you get we
call consensus smooth deep tearing
images do that these are ten such images
from time different random
initialization so you see a lot more
consistency than the a-team models which
actually I was quite happy with for a
while and that's what we underway so
when we submitted the paper I'm pretty
empirical this is so what I want to see
is that to close up weeks a closed loop
experiment and just feed it in and see
things work and it's the surgical
analysis it's kind of is how do you
formulate a scientific interpretation
question two mathematical framework I
think that's very challenging you can
maybe take bits of it so while my poster
Dominic said that he can you pour the
general stability principle you can show
that has has a really good like
to medical negative results
yeah maybe I would talk to you about it
yeah so right now it's it's empirical as
I said we are very empirical this days
and we're coming back to theory for your
ad model do need to guarantee that the
few nurses is the same so so remember I
take three different vgg could go night
and so they have the same a filter size
and then for each of the three I took 3
layers so for the and the other nine
come because rich and the soup so about
six of them share the same pewter size
they're different pizzas a little
different my experience with teacher
unions that it loves to bring out
pattern better you know kind of nice to
look at
I wonder I'm curious if you've done
found any neurons that doesn't respond
to anything so if you do this then it's
just black damage
you need a real neuron you're yeah we
mutate get patterns but we don't look at
those things about the prediction
accuracy is pretty bad
so we concentrate on the ones which we
predict pretty well and then you see
patterns even for the bad one you see
pattern but we don't trust them but we
do do smoothing right so we have some
like nearby pizza smoothing as a
regularization to the optimization this
is super that's why I call this
hypothesis generation and to struggle
with something that we're happy with as
a team so that which is consensus the
images with good new rounds that means
they have I think over pond5 and then
you can now cluster them you recover a
lot of the behavior which people know
already which is this various geometric
design for the stimuli and people know
there's texture there's also curvature
the small complex pattern also see
things like this this is really like a
ball future but has much bigger
receptive field so it makes sense that
people know that in v1 in before you
also have kind of V by like H detectors
that was a bigger receptive you that
means the neuron cares of a bigger
region of the image that smell when us
we want like a bowl and then we send the
paper out and I think one of the people
who really know this tower had really
very helpful reviews it's really
questioning which part of the image in
deep tune it's really captured a neuron
which are artifacts of the motor so we
define to decompose it into smaller bits
and you see a compounding in fact
because the convolutional filters
compound the result these do the you
marriage so you have a higher higher
responses because the different curves
got on top of each other up the
convolution later
you see the same thing for some texture
there too
we also decompose it into pieces you see
each had some reaction but you do see a
compound behavior I have the whole image
and if you go back to this you can see
that this period it's much much smaller
than this we believe this is an artifact
of the size of the convolution of you
turn so you can now really interpret the
whole thing untidy small locally we
think might be more interval so this
drive because we don't believe the whole
picture is really driven by the neuron
but it's because the artifact of the
model we're gonna try to do almost
identical argumentation you basically
randomly
permute this small part of it as input
to the close of experiment so a set we
have me on the same track at the collar
Scoob they actually just published a
paper they beat us because Jack my
collaborator she stopped doing
physiology experiments so that's why we
didn't have any access student have to
graduate so so but we're pretty pleased
that they basically had their version of
this very similar idea population
science to show that you can use this to
design closed-loop experiments and so as
scientists in training I'm pretty happy
with kind of on the same track as a top
lab instead of getting disappointed if I
bring back the PDR angle predictive
accuracy to script equity and relevance
you can see that
we have state of our prediction
performance on the test data and we have
sparsity and lastly if you take the LA
Zoo model or you do stretch holding at
the ridge
we have modularity because the different
units and the first layer Gabor because
we use a future question it's very
interpret both and because scientists
really believe that the first layer is
like a goal relevancy we think that it's
relevant to computational neuroscientist
so right now we actually rewrite in the
paper jack is going through the paper
with my students on line by line because
Jack's goal is to write a paper so that
the hundred year from now people can
still read it and he really has very
high writing standards I'm learning too
I don't know how to write a set to be
honest a my student being trained and
he's really sitting and down going line
by line and so I think if you want
something good I think usually takes
hard work that's my belief
so maybe news and you find interesting
and maybe the deep learning community
that I'm giving a tough line is
interesting as well and the closed loop
experiments will be very important next
steps so actually this tip to me it's a
special case of a general framework my
group has been working on I have been
advocating I'll call pcs workflow she
really tried to build some statistical
ideas an expanded way on top of machine
learning so in the beginning I was
working with Jack like 15 years so we're
just doing machine learning doing
prediction and now I want to do
experiments also to interpret so that's
why we introduced this stability idea as
idea from uncertainty a mystical if you
look at uncertainty measure institute
it's really about perturbation which is
another data set from the same
distribution if you look at the whole
data science lifecycle you have problem
formulation you have a language
stability issue I have multiple team of
people from different areas to the
understanding English language or
another language in the same way and
data perturbation was advocating my 2013
paper and I go back to two key because
actually two key lecture and use a
modern fancy term actually I would say
that two key made adverse
attack on sample mean in the 50s right
it is he added a liar to show that the
sample mean is now stable and then the
whole future robust statistics became a
subfield when people consider our Liars
influence function some that idea have
been also brought back to the plural
interpretation and this PGH framework
really require a documentation so that's
the goal it's really bring some liberal
are thinking into data science and data
work to really argue as I think
discussed earlier what's the right
perturbation for particular problem well
see area I can see you have constraints
you might have only to do population
maybe you can argument it with some salt
for simulation maybe you do laplacian
you do something else and maybe go to a
low dimension do the perturbation
because not all the perturbation is
equally likely and that node I was
thinking in the first talk was actually
unique for the framing I saw was really
about if you know there's kind of attack
you can do certification but you real
wild they're diverse really not gonna
tell you how they can attack you so
maybe some games tragic point of view
will be helpful here to really have a
random strategy to really us certify
your algorithm so that virtual actually
doesn't know what you're gonna use so
you play this game and you have probably
in wired I think would be a lot more our
bet on that then busy cell to perturb
the certified results mr. t vacations
very assuring but there are conditions
so that's the thing people keep saying I
want guarantees but without saying what
conditions you have the guarantees under
you really cannot apply that to practice
because the conditions never met
impractical guarantees are not relevant
in terms of data perturbation where you
have this typical perturbation the iid
setting foot straps up sampling and
adding smarter noise and now it's called
data documentation this community
actually O'Brien was advocating in the
90s and Institute we also have
you take residuals and then you ain't
noise to it and not just data
argumentation through noise you can also
run mechanistic models like I think
Peter abuse group actually do some PD
driven robots arm reaching to an object
and you can put that in also so this pcs
form to try to incorporate out of that
an adversary perturbations has been
exist at least since the crash in
banking it's called stretch stress
testing I want to change things so that
the bank will have enough reserve so
that won't go bankrupt so a lot of these
concepts have been existed and the one
related to Alexander's is actually I
think he was talking about robust
features it's really he's kind of
getting at causality trillion variance
so that's what I was also getting as
through that as high Paula narration so
you have causalities implies
predictability when you add stability or
robustness you have a stronger case for
inter parity and also causality and
there's a line of work people since the
forties from economics that people have
been using invariants to seek so
causality grab causality is a very
strong form interpret bility so back to
comfortability in deep tune that you
have basically gradient based right we
didn't train the model we trained the
sewerage and abet gradient descent and
deep tune is agreed in ascent or descent
so this is the first one very much
embedded in a scientific community try
to do science with a scientific
collaborator and the second project I
would say that is small machine learning
in the sense that we want a generic way
of interpreting deep learning models
especially for case by case not just for
the average a model and can we visualize
understand a way for human consumption
so all of this at the post hoc
interpretation previous gradient based
message and we'll compare which the one
which is more used and computational
physical to ig integrate gradients and
there's also contribution based based so
you remove a certain part of the image
or zeroed it out and see how the
prediction accuracy changed so this is
ideas relate to the O'Briens idea in the
importance measure in a random forest
you didn't remove it
he actually scrambled up tab the
marginal distribution so you could in
Syria also do that and just take a
random piece of in there and then see
how to change our compare ways to
occlusion or CNC map this is very much
Jamie's work that he started with the OS
TN for sentiment analysis and you have a
movie and LSE I'm gonna spew up a
positive sentiment and we hope to have
also explanation that will be so why the
movie was positive and they were already
important scores but language not just
random ensemble of words their
relationships
there's compositionality of the words
that make a meaning so you have to you
have only two important scores but not
and good there's no way you can describe
than not good you have unions
just enough so you have to go beyond
word importance and Jamie I think was
working his Peter at Google brain and
came back I kind of help a bit after he
came back that he was really going after
something that you can do all three
right you can easily get out from out LS
TM prediction again stated the waste
we're not feeling and you decompose it
right into a self max in the last and
you're doing classification into two
terms the first term correspond to a
particular phrase which can be one word
two words three or any and then you
write the other part into the other
times and we're going to try to
interpret the gamma team I recently that
was an ocular 2018 paper Chandan and
Jamie they follow up on that and did a
agglomerative contactor decomposition
and to also generalize to the images so
in short a CD is a hierarchical
clustering economist virtualization by
using the CD scores because we have CD
scores for not just one word but also
for phrases and we also have a very nice
visualization for that so if I put the a
CD through the lines of PDR in terms of
information learning we're not changing
the prediction accuracy because we're
taking already faded model and the
script accuracy allows for description
in terms of any sub of the future space
and for saamana will also visualize and
the relevancy is ready to machine
learners devolve maybe you can identify
by so going back like why so very
interesting try some of these applying
peak examples to see where our
importance measure will keep suggestions
that's why some of the and you really
taking out to the user term Alex like
robust features or now robust features
so this is both ways Valley they
understand
hopefully this robust Messrs and also
try to validate what we do whether make
sense so when they try they try this
particular way I mean us working in
general you can make sure you try a
defense to interpret ability that you
with in some senses defeating the
preference of the tupid ability metric
interpretability method is trying to say
that we can in general tell me why a
prediction was made some way they'd like
to defend that against attack it's
probably not doing the right thing to
begin with yes if you try to learn one
but as soon as you say well I'm gonna do
smoothing and pgdavis or me protect my
interpretability metric against
adversarial attacks this is
self-defeating in some sense I think you
might be right but I like to try and
then see what happens because I think
it's a little different the way we
collected the information Jamie do you
want to add I'll just say that a lot of
interpretation techniques out there kind
of stuck right now and so that you know
you're able to make that you were able
to show another way that they suck is
not all that shocks me I think that what
we've done doesn't suck
tgd on this and I would put I don't know
sorry yeah I mean I don't know sir okay
so let me finish people you guys can
debate it out after the talk I'm I
cannot stick I want to see evidence and
I'll believe yeah so this is have only
two minutes so this is a which this
hierarchical interpretation you can see
that we have this scale this is positive
this negative this is more positive this
is neutral this is slightly positive and
put you together you can get the whole
sentence being negative most
sophisticated way of a sentence it's a
similar thing you can really combine the
strengths of the context and put it
together to see how the sentiment
direction changed you can do the same
for images that so we have these
different classifications that you can
see that if you look at the class of
park then this identify that the skates
are also responsible to help to see this
apart right because they in real life
they are pretty correlated so you do
pick this out this just highlight the
important features for this particular
prediction acronym but I think like
everything you can be food so we should
try the adverse your attacks and I did a
small human experiments with eleven
graduate students from stats and you see
I said Berkeley and you can see the
first ones that we give them a good
model and bad-mouthed oh the bad mode is
made by random perturbing some of the
ways in a good model is the same class
label awesome which one is a good model
so you take find a good model student
interpretation they only give me the
interpretation then we said that they
got it right so you can see that the HDP
that's better than our own measured and
also interview gradient elution
and this is another data that to ask
people ranking the different
interpretations
what are trustworthy or not
you can see this is a very small
experiment and but so to finish so
webbing micro has really going after
interviewing various projects and
particularly in scientific machine
learning we hope to help by its
identification and also this general
prediction
computability and stability I think a
general framework we're building up and
also going to inference we have
something called perturbation intervals
which is a generalization company in
terms of why you don't have the
probability model in trust with you
can't you talk about perturbation
intervals we try to lay out a few
landmarks what we mean by interval
machine learning and we actually
collected a lot of examples in the paper
other people's work and put into this
framing talk about two particular
projects for interpretability in
neuroscience and also in general so
actually preparing for this talk as I
realized we should try to analyze our
deep two images through a CD but you
some people are not in Berkeley anymore
things are being slow so I don't have
anything to show you we also try to
translate these papers into like social
science and also medicine like this
general framework and thank you last not
least I'm working on a book which my
student Rebecca butter and hopefully you
try to help people to really get into so
where we really try to build the the
link between reality and the algorithm
so there's always a quantum leap a lot
of the textbooks I've did there for 20
or 30 years start with X right my first
lecture was a saying where the X come
from so this book attempt to fill that
gap so I think that's a weak link these
are items and imagine unimportant but
it's a very important link which in the
education
they got this beautiful poster for talk
she would give next week thank you so I
like that you read the human experiments
at the last in the lab sighs but I see
those two separate from different
abilities where in my opinion should
show when you shouldn't I'm curious to
see where you come from when you both
we did - right the first ones tried to
differentiate good and bad model right
so bad mother is kind of a stand-in for
no trustworthy thing right so we give
them like that a comparison the second
why is something in practice people
don't always have the luxury of having a
bad bottle to compare ways because
humans are very good at comparing things
the absolute scale we're not very good
so the second one Jamie can correct me
if I'm wrong that is try to go for
direct like people look at it well so
you actually
that's a great example of one you
shouldn't trust them all because that's
actually incorrect prediction that malls
made but if you look very the logic
there you can see that is up until the
last two phrases actually got everything
right
didn't even capture the negation of this
heart the last step and it's like the
correlation motorist about like you're
sort of maybe philosophical background
behind etiquette I try hard to like [ __ ]
like those too because if the trust is
your goal then you can just get
psychology to see how do we deceive
people as people are very easy to
deceive it was a magical multiple goals
right you don't always have only one
goal when people like him are those a
lot of things go through people's minds
I think actually looking at this
interpret bility found multiple angles
so if the newer science project I'm
Molly engaged with is that it's gonna be
a long drawn-out process before anything
what we do accepted by the community try
to have the colour scripting with us and
he actually visited him and we had the
background post discussion he actually
didn't keep on everything to be
automated so we tried to become like a
physiologist to loose visualization and
he actually rather to have everything
automated because he sings too much
humans are too wishy-washy so ad very
Intune debate would kind of set her in
the middle so both probably needed but
he pushed really really bad and I wish I
tried to do a sign take the science
tradition and he's like no that's all
science wanted new signs so I think you
need multiple angles that's where did a
kind of the also stability philosophical
principle that life is just very
complicated you need to see things from
multiple angles if they agree I'm
happier now if they don't agree you have
to make your back
we're out of time now so and it said
thank again our break